park nos voisins européens n'ont pas été
épargné par le mauvais temps
dix morts en allemagne 8 en suisse
julien colombani après la france la
tempête a continué sa course folle vers
le centre de l'europe c'est l'allemagne
qui a été la plus touchée dix personnes
ont été tuées dans le sud ouest du pays
on compte les blessés par dizaines les
victimes ont pour la plupart été écrasé
par la chute des arbres déracinés car là
aussi la violence de la tempête a tout
arraché les grues n'ont pas résisté aux
vents dépassant les 100 kilomètres heure
des pointes à 213 ont même été
enregistrés en forêt noire
le trafic a été partiellement stoppé des
dizaines de routes et d'autoroutes sont
restés bloqués pendant des heures 30
lignes de chemin de fer ont été coupées
et aucun avion n'a décollé de munich et
de stuttgart aujourd'hui de l'autre côté
de la frontière en suisse le bilan est
lui aussi très lourd huit morts rarement
le lac léman n'a pris de telle allure
d'océan une tempête digne des côtes
atlantiques a causé sur ses berges des
millions de francs de dégâts
même scénario qu'en france et en
allemagne peu de choses on résister à la
bourrasque une cabine de téléphérique
c'est même décroché faisant un mort et
deux blessés graves dans sa trajectoire
la tempête a atteint plusieurs autres
pays de l'europe du nord-ouest
les premiers à l'aube l'irlande et la
grande-bretagne ou cinq morts sont à
déplorer et la belgique où la flandre a
subi de graves inondations
en plus des dégâts causés par le vent
l'eau et la boue a déferlé dans les
maisons cette tempête est la plus forte
qui ait connu l'europe depuis dix ans à
cette époque elle avait fait 200
victimes